i guess i see dustin's in the chat um so
i might as well play that we might as
well play this if dustin's in the chat
uh mr dustin
mr dustin hope you're doing good pal
uh let's check out your new video oh
wrong
wrong overlay although that's a nice
thing day wave gaming overlay huh
pretty cool but we're not doing we're
not doing gaming
all right here we go
squad and my fellow youtubers as well
zombie squad welcome to the dustin tv
guys i'm gonna go ahead and say this um
i got some bad news
my girlfriend has
covered oh no and i hope
yeah she has coconut 19.
she was tested positive for it
that's the taste oh my zombie squad
please
please i am begging y'all please
pray for her because she really needs it
right now she is so scared
and worried about it please
i know god will be with her i want a lot
of prayers
on the comments down below come on pray
guys guys i'm begging you
more prayers more prayers guys
but here's another thing that [ __ ]
hospital she's in
uh-oh they knew the woman next to her
had coveted but i didn't want to do
nothing and guess what it affect my
my girlfriend that what pisses me off
about that stupid-ass hospital
there was my girlfriend's in they don't
give a
damn about their patience uh oh
tom oh dustin's getting upset
he and my girlfriend
is worried about the cobra her catching
it
and i'd be damned she caught it all
because
of the hospital the nurses
and the um and the managing
with that hospital don't give a damn
about these damn patients
man that what pisses me off with her
with that hospital she's in right now
that hospital got her sick
of the code [ __ ] that hospital dustin
[ __ ] him if they knew they
actually knew the woman next to my
girlfriend
had covered she was coughing coughing a
lot running a fever
and guess what i got my girlfriend sick
and she got coping
now she's [ __ ] scared yeah jacob
scott's right
this [ __ ] hospitals you run by the
third como brother is that what it is
is that what oh duh dustin i can't
[ __ ] believe this hospital
who do they think they are that's your
girl dog that's your girl dog
dog that's your girl stand up for your
girl
dog also pick up
pick up what's up hey so what's up dog
what happened the uh
the hospital got your chick sick yeah
okay can turn the computer down because
i can hear myself
i can hear myself hi future royce
hey yeah i got it turned down
what happened uh well there was a woman
next to her
women are terrible i'm with you women
are horrible
it was a woman next to her was coughing
dirty vaginas they didn't realize
she had cobit in and
she was coughing and it got in the air
and
king got covered i'm with you man
first off how's she doing i'm trying to
get a hold of her i've been trying to
call her and everything
and and hopefully she's not on the
ventilator wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait when last
you talked to her what did she tell you
uh the last time she talked to me she
was getting where she
want to breathe and then they put her on
oxygen
and they also put her in a room by
herself
and when was this a couple days ago
and you haven't talked to her since
i tried to tried and
and it's just no answer
have they told you have they told you
anything can you call the hospital
uh i tried and they didn't
because i'm not a family member i told
him i was her
i was her boyfriend but they still
wouldn't
still wouldn't you know
tell me anything and the last you spoke
to her she needed oxygen you said
well she was getting where she's going
her breathe and
then she called me back and i can she
said they just put her on oxygen
and she was getting little words out
gasping for air
i was like oh [ __ ] and this was two days
ago
a couple days ago can you call can you
is there a way to call her family and
ask her
uh she already called him before
um when she had the cover she called him
to tell them
but she didn't give me no number of her
her family because her mom and dad
passed away
oh [ __ ] yeah so you don't even have
you can't even call her family to see
what's going on
i'm just kind of wearing me though
yeah i'd be worried what city is she in
or what state
um she's on the state is above
uh north carolina
she's she's in the state above north
carolina
yeah i don't don't know the the state
you're not a big state guy
well i just only know certain states i
can
you know but i don't know like states
right up
above north carolina she's in it she's
in there
in that state in the hospital but she's
from florida
so are you talking about are you talking
about virginia does she live in virginia
virginia
all right yeah she's in the rehab in
virginia she's been in
in that rehab hospital for
maybe about two three years for
because she had seizures and stuff
so she has jesus christ us then i feel
terrible man i i'm sorry i'm really
sorry to hear that i hope she's okay
and plus uh my friends uh tina tv
and justin tv they went to church
i think yesterday and they got the whole
church praying for
uh so so she lives she lives in virginia
she's in the hospital
uh you can't get in contact with her how
long have you guys been going out for
uh about three years
three years yeah
uh i guess there's really not much you
could do right
no the only thing i can't do is just
keep praying
all right hear you
oh you know i got my skype up and ready
oh yeah yep i got my skype
i added you on skype
really i then i probably could get you
on uh
yeah that's the reason why i got my
skype up
well man look we'll we'll uh oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] now i gotta find
you said you added me i mean see if i
find it hold on a second
did you send me a chat message or
something so i could find you
yeah i uh oh let me uh get on my
chat with my
take your time don't worry
i said hi oh well i haven't i haven't
seen it
what's your skype name um
dustin stevens with a ph
oh i see you there you are i see you
you see me with the little dog yes yes i
see you with the little dog hey why
don't you hang up and i'll call you from
there okay
all right bye all right bye-bye
by the way before i call him i think oh
this is getting yeah you're right let's
not be
let's not be human beings let's just be
[ __ ] animals to somebody who's been
nothing but nice to us she wrote this
isn't
this guy's [ __ ] girlfriend's dying
this is entertaining to me then [ __ ]
beat it
honestly go [ __ ] yourself jesus christ
man hey what's up
what's up whoa that's loud hold on
wow buddy that's really loud there you
are
there you are let me let me pull you up
here so people could see you hold on
let me let me uh switch this up here for
everybody here
uh let's see here
there we go there you are there you are
all right now we see you
so yeah man i really do hope everything
everything does work out
i really do yeah i hope so
too yeah i like your haircut
oh thanks you should probably cut a
promo on that stupid hospital
oh in the video i actually did
oh you did you cut a promo on them
well i was really pissed off
yeah so you should but you should [ __ ]
them
but i mean there's got to be a way to
get more information you don't know
anybody else in the family
um no
i sure don't ah [ __ ]
does she she does she has other she has
underlying conditions though right you
said she has seizures and stuff
yes she has seizures asthma
and i heard that she said she has
lung cancer too wait wait whoa whoa whoa
whoa she has lung cancer
that's what she told me but if she has
lung cancer then i mean
then that it's not really so much the
covet it might be the lung cancer man
well she was they tested a positive wait
did she just find out she had lung
cancer
yes she just found out she had uh
lung cancer does she smoke
nope she never smoked
so she just went to the hospital
well she went to the hospital because
she when she had a seizure
um she get where she couldn't walk
and they put her in a rehab hospital
after they had her in the hospital
to get her strength up in her legs again
let me ask you a question
where did just i'm just trying to piece
some of this together where did you
where did you
where did you meet uh hen at um
actually a friend of mine um uh actually
his uh channel is uh
texas paranormal he's a good friend of
mine and how did he
how did he meet her how did he meet her
uh he met her on um
somebody was doing like um
like trying to think of it now
they was doing this ghost stuff and and
rudy was good friends with him
and that's where he met her at
and then after i was doing videos
and she likes my singing and that's when
rudy gave her my number and she calls me
and i call her and that's where we met
have you ever have you ever met her in
person
never met her in person have you ever
video chatted with her
yeah so you have seen her yeah i have
seen
her she looks beautiful okay i know i'm
just curious
and she called you to tell you that she
had coveted
well yes well she i was actually
live on youtube and
that's when she says 9-1-1
i'm like 9-1-1 oh what's going on here
and that's when she said she had bad
news
then she calls me that's when she told
me
she has coveted do you ever help her out
do you ever like send her money and
stuff
i've been trying to uh get her to send
me her
the address and everything but she never
did
okay so you've never sent her money or
anything no
okay um
hmm and and do you only have one way to
get in contact with her that's her cell
phone correct
yeah um her yeah her cell phone
or um ah
try to think of it messenger
messenger and you said that she doesn't
have any she doesn't have any family
yes she has family she has um
her daughter and her other son she has a
daughter how old is she
around she is maybe in her late
or late or middle in her 40s
so she's in her late four late 40s
probably uh she's been late for and how
old are you again dustin
i'm 33 i like older women well that's
fine i'm not judging you you don't
trust me i'm not judging you i'm just
i'm just tr you remember i'm trying to
piece this together
yeah yeah yeah yeah i understand that
i'm just trying to understand
and then she says she had kovitz she
went to the hospital
how old's her daughter oh she's probably
in her mid late 20s okay because she has
a
because she has a kid and it's
her grand uh well he his real name is
kim
okay now yeah don't doctor i don't want
her real info i would
i don't want it i don't want anybody
knowing your real info but that's fine
that's fine so but
but but so so
her daughter so you there's no way to
get in contact with her daughter to kind
of find out what's going on
um because she never give me her
daughter's number
i mean is her daughter maybe on facebook
is there a way to get in contact with
her daughter that way
well she never she never uh she
said her name she never said her full
name
um the only thing i can do is just pray
and and hope for the best no no hey man
you're a good person i'm not
no way am i judging you dustin i really
do think you're all joking you should
decide i do think you're a really good
person i'm just trying to understand
what's going on that the fact that you
can't get in contact that you don't know
what's happening
um and you talk to her all the time
how often do you talk to her normally uh
a lot of times she calls me if i'm busy
and i try to call her like maybe
once or twice a day and and
i can't get a hold of her was she
married before
yeah she was married and they got
divorced i'm assuming
yeah they got divorced how long ago
uh i really don't know because she never
told me
but you guys are dating yeah we're
dating
i will light from like to go get her but
now she has the coveted you know
let her get go through it and get better
i would like before all this covey crap
started
i would love to went go get her and bro
bro bring her home
and take care of her
huh
um and she's never she's never asked you
for money or anything huh
no she she's never asked
asked me for money all right no just i'm
you know i'm just looking out for you
dustin that's all yeah i know
i know and the last you spoke to her
she was on oxygen and that's all you
know yeah
that's all i know so she has here's
oxygen she has seizures
and she has lung cancer she may have
lung cancer they say she has lung cancer
she may have lung cancer
she says she has lung cancer
but she's scared to death right now i
mean i've been trying to call her
hey how about this morning i tried to
call her again but never
get answer
huh and you really did nothing you could
do now you said but pray and then
hopefully you get in contact with her
yeah so when you call her phone now what
happens it goes to voicemail
no it is she keeps ringing the ring and
ringing
i call her her cell phone and i get on
messenger
and try to call her that way too
all right well just yeah be careful
dustin that's all i guess the internet's
a weird place you know what i mean
yeah you know i'm just looking out for
you man the internet's a weird place
just be careful with that stuff
yeah but you know the hospital is
supposed to be the safest place to be
but well i mean not in new york
um well it seems like that hospital
don't really give a [ __ ] about the
patients
were you guys ever planning on meeting
in person
yeah we was we was planning on meeting
it was before she was
in rehab hospital now you're a sweet guy
uh
you're you're a sweet guy dustin and i
mean that legitimately
have you ever thought of of um i don't
know maybe
trying to date people around your your
own age range and stuff maybe someone
lives around you in florida or florida
excuse me in alabama
or georgia sorry george i keep
forgetting georgia
well i'm in the um
pick up pick up pick up pick up cop pick
up don't worry about me pick up
pick up and let me know hang on i'll
hang up i'll hang up pick up
all right all right all right bye
[Music]
hmm
well what a surprise she's being able to
get the call in now huh
i
i want to make sure that i i look i i
really do like dustin i think he's a
good person you know that i've been very
clear about that
we're gonna call him back we're gonna
see what's uh what's what's new but
hmm
hmm
wow just the rabbit holes this show is
is
is a series if you want martin davis at
the beginning you'll know this but
it is a series of rabbit holes